el palacio de buckingham ha anunciado la
muerte su majestad la reina isabel
segunda esa gente con la muerte de
isabel segunda se activó una gran
operación logística y de protocolo
conocida como london bridge todo estaba
previsto con años de antelación diez
días llenos de simbolismos ceremonias y
rituales a partir del deceso como la
jefa de estado falleció en el palacio de
balmoral escocia se activó otro plan de
contingencia llamado y unicorn que
incluía su paso por escocia y su
traslado a londres en menos de 48 horas
su hijo y heredero al trono fue
proclamado de manera formal por el
consejo de ascensión carlos tercero fue
el nombre escogido por el nuevo rey por
primera vez en la historia del país se
transmitía esta ceremonia por televisión
[Música]
[Aplausos]
dos fechas después de su muerte el
cortejo fúnebre de la reina se traslado
de balmoral a edimburgo capital de
escocia allí permaneció otros dos días
una procesión hasta la catedral de saint
gilles y varias ceremonias religiosas
antes de que la soberana quedará
expuesta en capilla ardiente- fueron las
principales actividades luctuosas
y posteriormente el cuerpo fue llevado a
londres al palacio de buckingham donde
pasó la noche antes de su siguiente
traslado y otros rituales protocolarios
entretanto el rey carlos tercero
desarrollar una gira por las naciones
que componen el reino como carta de
presentación ante sus parlamentos y
principales dirigentes andrés pib des de
buckingham otro procedimiento daba
comienzo dentro del don don bridge la
operación line así se denominó la
ceremonia militar de transporte de los
restos a westminster hall la sala del
parlamento británico donde también han
sido veladas otras personalidades como
winston churchill allí permaneció por
cuatro días hasta el funeral de estado
en la abadía de westminster en la décima
jornada durante esos cuatro días varios
fueron los homenajes realizados en todo
el país
líderes mundiales y personalidades de
distintos sectores de la sociedad
llegaron al sitio el domingo el rey
carlos tercero ofreció una recepción
para cientos de ellos y durante esos
días miles de personas hicieron una fila
de varios kilómetros hasta por 24 horas
para rendir tributo a isabel segunda en
la capilla ardiente